Hey everyone, I'm Jinang fromWent team
Alib to be here in AI engineer world
fair 205 and I'm very excited to share
some progress about quen to all of you.
I think you guys know about quen and uh
maybe you are developers I'm very happy
to share some more things about Gwen to
all of you. is a large a series of large
language models and large multimodel
models and uh we have a dream of
building a journalist model and
generalist agent and before I start I
would like to share some important links
to all of you uh maybe you know our
product our chat interface quench chat
uh which is chat.quen.ai AI uh it is
very easy to use. You can interact with
our latest models. You can use our
multimodel models uh by uploading images
and videos and you can also interact
with our omni models using voice chat
and video chat. And there are some
important features like webdev and um
deep research. Welcome to enjoy it. And
uh if you like to know more about
technical details, you can check our
blog which is
quen.github.io. in our blog. Uh once we
release something new, we often uh
release a blog. So you would can know
more about technical details uh through
our blogs. Uh as we keep open sourcing
so uh we have our codes in GitHub and uh
we have our checkpoints in hugging base.
So you can download our checkpoints and
play with our models. Yeah. Um so feel
free to uh check our websites and enjoy
them. Yep.
uh in this year just before the spring
festival we have released uh very good
instruction tune models I think it's a
very good basis uh for larger language
models which is when 2.5 max it is a
very large models and we find that um in
multiple benchmarks uh it achieves very
very competitive performance to the
state-of-the-art models at that time
including colog 3.5 GBD 40 and DCB v3
three uh but we uh we uh we believe that
there are more potential for a large
language model not just becoming an
instruction tune model but it can uh be
smarter and smarter with reinforcement
learning. So we have dived into uh doing
the research in reinforcement learning
and we finally found that well it is
really amazing to see that you using RL
can increase its performance especially
in breathing task like math and coding
and in increase the performance quite
consistently uh just like for for am 20
uh 24 for a 32 billion parameter model
you you can find that its performance uh
starting from like 65 and is it
increasing until it is 80. So it is
really amazing to build a reasoning
model like Q and also in triple arena
you can find that its performance uh is
also very competitive with even larger
models and it is in uh top 15 for for a
long time. So we would like to combine
all our uh efforts uh in our research uh
and development to build a stronger next
generation models. So very very recently
we have released Gwen 3. Gwen 3 is our
latest large language models and we have
released multiple sizes of dense and
models with a large number of models. Uh
first of all I would like to share the a
flagship model to auto which is a um 20
uh
235 billion parameter model. It was a
total number but only activates 22
billion parameter models. um uh it is
ane models so it is actually efficient
but it's very effective in comparison
with uh very top tier models like 03
mini and it's just lagging a little bit
behind uh Gemini 2.5 Pro and also for
for our largest dense model it's also
very competitive as uh as well and we
have a very very fast models it is
relatively small although it has 30
billion total parameter models only
activate three billion parameter models.
But if you compare the performance with
Q32 billion, the MOE models which only
activate three billion parameter models
even can out compete Q32 billion in some
task. And for a even smaller models very
small it is only 4 billion parameter
models but this time we have a lot of
techniques uh in distillation distilling
large the knowledge from large model to
small models. We finally built a very
good small models and with thinking
capabilities it even shows
competitiveness to the flagship model in
our last ver uh iteration like quen
2.572b. Yeah. So it is a really good
model and it is really worth a try for
you to play with our 4 billion parameter
model and the 4 billion parameter model
and you can even deploy it in mobile
devices. Yeah. So for quen 3 we have
some important features and the most
important features this time it is
hybrid thinking mode. So what is hybrid
thinking mode? Hybrid thinking mode
means that you can use thinking and
non-thinking in a single model. We
combine the two behaviors into a model.
What is thinking mode? Uh thinking is
like uh before you answer the question
uh with an an uh detailed answer. You
just start thinking. You just reflect on
yourself, explore possibilities. Finally
you find that well you are ready to
answer the question so you provide the
answer. So uh like 01 and deep R1 they
have the thinking behavior. Yeah. And
for non-thinking mode it is just a
traditional uh instruction tune model.
It's just like a chatbot without
thinking without lagging. It is just
provide the answer. It is near instant.
But this might be the first time in the
open source community that we combine
the two modes uh into a single model. So
you can use prompts or hyperparameters
to control its behaviors as you like.
And once we dive into the hybrid
thinking modes, we find that we can
create a feature of dynamic thinking
budget. So what is dynamic thinking
budgets? For thinking budgets, which
means the maximum thinking tokens. For
example, if you have 32,000 tokens for
your thinking budget. So, uh for a task
which requires thinking, for example, if
you finish the thinking with like 8,000
tokens, it is um below 32,000. Okay,
fine. You finish thinking, provide the
answer. Is it good? But if you only have
a thinking budget of 4,000
tokens, so um uh if if your thinking
requires more than 4,000 tokens, like
you requires 8,000 tokens to finish your
thinking, but you only have a budget of
4,000 tokens. So you will stop at 4,000
tokens, which means that your thinking
process is truncated. So uh we can check
the performance with uh larger and
larger thinking budgets and you'll find
that well the performance increase quite
well with the increase of thinking
budgets and uh with a very small
thinking budget uh for example in AM 24
it only achieves just over 40 but if you
have a large thinking budget like 32,000
tokens you can even achieve more than
80. It is really really amazing with the
thinking capabilities. So uh I hope you
enjoy the hybrid thinking mode. You you
only single model to achieve thinking
and non non-thinking and you'll find
something uh good for you. For example
uh in your task you require only like 95
uh uh% accuracy and you will find that
well uh for
example you use only 8,000 tokens for
your thinking budget you can achieve
over 95%. So that is quite well. You
don't need to waste more tokens on your
thinking. So you don't can keep your
thinking budgets with 8,000 tokens. This
is only an example. We would like to
explore the usages. Yeah. The next
important features is that Quen 3
supports over
119 languages and dialects. In Quen 2.5,
it only supports 29 languages, but this
time we support over
119 languages and dialects. We have uh
detail uh names of uh the languages and
dialects that we support. You can check
it. I think it will be really good for
global applications and there are a lot
of people uh previously uh especially if
they are you using open web model. the
open way models don't support many
languages quite well. So there will be
more people that are capable of using uh
large language models in in the domains
and in the languages. Yeah.
And we have spe uh specifically
increased the capabilities uh in uh
agents and codings and especially we
enhanced the support uh for MCP which is
really po popular uh very recently and
and these are two examples to show that
uh our models how to use tools during
thinkings. who will find that uh it can
think while it uh it is using a function
calls to use the tools and it gets the
feedbacks from the environment and it
keeps thinking. So that would be a
feature that we really prefer which is
the model is capable of thinking but it
is also capable of interacting with the
environment and it keeps thinking. It is
really good for like uh inference time
scaling. And this is another example for
the model to organize the desktop. So uh
if it has the access to the file system,
it can do things like that. It thinks uh
which tools should it use and then it
use the tools and gets the feedback and
continues thinking while uh it finish
the you using the tools and it finished
the task and tell you that well you we
have organized the de desktop quite
well. And these are two very simple uh
examples to show that uh we have
provided better and better support for
uh agent capabilities. And we not only
would like our models to be a simple
chatbot, we would like it to be really
productive in our working life to become
a really really productive agent. Yeah.
And uh these are three features of
um three. Yeah. Uh we have open weighted
uh a lot of sizes um including twoe
models. uh a small model has a total
number of 30 billion and only activates
three billion but uh another one is 235
billion activates um 20 20 uh 22 billion
parameter models. Yeah, we also have six
dense models and for smaller models you
can use it for testing and you can
support draft models but for four
billion parameter model models you can
deploy it uh on mobile devices and for
32 billion parameter models that these
are models that uh you really prefer and
especially 32 billion parameter model it
is strong uh this shows competitiveness
and you can use it for doing doing RL
you can deploy it uh uh in in your lo
local environ environment as well. So we
also open weighted um uh desk models as
well. But we believe that in this year
maybe in the next years the future trend
is belonging to the MOE models. So later
we will release more models for you to
use and there will be better support in
the open source community like thirdarty
frameworks for the models as well. Yeah
besides building large language models
we are also building multimodel models.
We have focused quite a lot on vision
language models and uh I think uh many
of you maybe are using quenu and now
using quen 2.5 VL which was released uh
this year in January. Uh it achieves a
very competitive performance uh in uh
vision language uh benchmarks uh like
understanding benchmarks like MMU and
also math benchmark like math vista and
also general uh a lot of general VQ VQA
benchmarks. So achieved very good
performance in the uh benchmarks for uh
vision language understanding. Um we
also explore the capabilities of
thinking for vision language model. So
we have uh built QVQ as well and we find
inverse time scaling with larger maximum
thinking length which is equivalent to
the thinking budget that I talked
before. So if you have a larger thinking
budget it will achieve better and better
performance uh in reasoning task
especially u uh like mathematics uh even
for vision language models it shows uh
similar features as well. Um but for
multimodel models we what we really
would like to do is to build an omni
model which accepts multimodalities
uh for the inputs and also it is capable
of generating multiple modalities uh
like text vision and audios but this
time um this is not the a perfect state
but I think it's good it's a relatively
a small model but we are really proud of
this attempt it's a 7 billion large
language model it's based on it. But it
is capable of accepting three modalities
including text, vision. Vision includes
uh images and videos and also uh it can
accept uh a audio and this time it can
generate text and audio. Maybe in the
future our models might be capable of
generating images, high quality images
and videos that will be a truly omni
models. Now for this omni model it is it
can be used in uh voice chat and video
chat and text chat as well. Um it
achieves state performance uh in audio
tasks uh for for for the same size
models like 7 billion parameter models.
uh but what surprised us a little bit is
that uh it can even achieve better
performance in vision language
understanding house in comparison with
quen 2.5 VL 7 billion which means that
um we can achieve very good performance
for an omni model in vision language
tasks but uh a little bit that we had
not done well but we believe we can done
we can do well is that uh we should
recover the performance drop in language
task uh especially for its intelligence
uh especially for its uh agent task. I
think we can recover it uh uh by
improving our data quality, improving
our training training methods. But now
um there are still some room for
improving uh uh the model capabilities
in different domains and different
tasks. Uh and this is the uh omni models
and no matter what models we keep open
sourcing. We love open sourcing because
open sourcing really helps us quite a
lot. Um by uh the developers can give us
some feedbacks to help us uh improve our
models. the interaction with the C uh
open source community uh makes us happy
and makes us um we have more we are more
encouraged to build more good models to
for for all of you. Yeah, we have a lot
of titled models uh in the open source
communities including LLMs and also
coders and quento.5 coders uh is
something that uh many people are using
for local development and something that
I can tell you that we are now building
quen three coders. I think you guys know
about it. Yeah. Um we have many model
sizes because we we just believe that
for each size there might be a lot of
users and actually there are there are a
lot of users no matter very very small
models like 0.6 6 billion parameter
models and there are a large models
previously 72 billion dense models and
now 235 billion models. There are a lot
of users using it and they need
quantized models. So we've just provide
quantized models in different formats
including GUM, GBQ, AWQ and MOX for
Apple as well. We try to use Apache 2.0
for most models. So you can just use it
freely. you can change the models freely
uh in your business. You don't need to
worry about too many things. You don't
need to access uh for the permission.
You just directly use it. We hope that
large language models and large
multimodel models or foundation models
can help you create good applications
and this is what we like to do and uh as
we are becoming popular and popular
during these two years. So for quen
models uh it should be supported by a
lot of maybe most uh rel uh rel relative
third party frameworks and API platforms
as well. Yeah and we are also building
products we are also building products
for for you to interact with our models.
We are building agents as well and in
our quad just as I uh mentioned before
we have some uh very good features. This
is something that I really like which is
called web deck. Um, by entering webdev,
you just need to insert or input a very
simple prompt. Uh, things like create a
Twitter website and we'll find that it
just generates a code uh and then uh
some effects like artifacts. So you you
have a website um to to see how how it
is shown and you can also deploy as
well. You can deploy it and get the URL,
share it to your friends to show that
how creative you are. You can also
create a website uh for your product.
For example, this is a very simple
prompt. Create a sunscreen product
introduction website and you have a very
good website. You can even click on the
buttons as well. And for making a card
uh not not just making a website just by
making a card. Well, it it generates a
card. I I really like the card. We we
often use the card in our Twitter. So,
uh our promise is also simple. We give
it a link. So, based on the link, you
just create a nice looking card and we
provide more information to you. You
just based on the information and build
a card for for us. Yeah. Um this is
something I really really like webdev uh
uh makes me more creative and helps me
quite a lot to show our things to all to
to people all over the world. Yeah, we
also have things like deep research uh
by doing deep research um you just need
to ask something to write a report uh in
what you are interested in. Yeah, maybe
like healthcare industry, maybe like
artificial intelligence. Just ask it.
Give it a prompt and it will ask you
what you are going to focus on. You can
tell it and you or or you can just say
as you like and it will start doing
research by making a plan first and then
doing the search step by step, writing
parts step by step. Yeah.
and keep
searching and finally gives a
comprehensive report to all of you. You
can download our report by a PDF. We are
still improving uh its quality by uh
doing reinforcement learning to build a
fine-tune model specifically for deep
research and we believe that there's
still much room uh in this field. It is
really hard to do reinforcement learning
uh for this talk but um once you have
built a good model for uh for this
product it will be really productive for
people uh in their working life. Yeah.
So in the future we will do many things
uh there are still a lot of things for
us to do to achieve AGI to build a
really good foundation model and
foundation agent for all of you. And the
first thing is that uh something really
different from what other people think.
We still believe that there is still
much room in training. Um I'm happy that
you uh you have shown your preference uh
in our uh pre-training models. Uh but we
still find that there are still a lot of
good data we did not put into it. Uh
there are still a lot of data we did not
clean it quite well. And we find that we
can use multimodel data and to make the
models more uh capable uh in doing
different tasks in different domains.
And we also have synthetic datas and
maybe we'll finally do something really
really different training methods for
pre-training not just like next token
prediction. Maybe later we use
reinforcement learning in pre-raining as
well. And so there is still much room uh
in pre-training to build a very good
basis for the uh chatbot or agents. And
this is the first thing and the second
thing is that uh the scaling laws uh
there are some changes in scaling law.
Previously we're scaling uh in the model
sizes in the pre-training data but now
we need to scale the compute uh in
reinforcement learning and we have a
focus on long horizon reasoning uh with
the environment feedback. So uh if you
train model which is capable of
interacting with the environment keep
thinking this will be something really
really uh competitive. So it will get
the feedback from the environment keeps
thinking it will become smarter and
smarter with inference time scaling.
Yeah. So you'll find that it it will
generate very very long
context and you'll have very long
context for your input uh especially
when you have memory. So you need to
scale your context. Maybe finally we are
moving towards infinite context but now
we need to fix the problems of one
million tokens uh quite well and then we
are marching to 10 million tokens and
then infinite context. So we are scaling
context uh we're going to scale the
context at least 1 million tokens this
year for most of our models. Yeah, we're
also going to scale modalities. Um may
maybe scaling on modalities doesn't
increase your intelligence but uh if you
scale on modalities you can make your
models more capable and more productive.
uh especially with the vision language
understanding you you if you have vision
language understanding capability you
can make a like GUI agent but before
that if you have no vision capability
you can it is almost impossible for you
to make a GUI agent and do things like
uh uh computer use and um maybe there is
still much room uh in uh scaling the
modalities in either inputs and outputs
uh we are going to unifying
understanding and gener generation. For
example, for for the image understanding
and image generation at the same time
just like GPT4 they generate u very
interesting uh and high quality uh
images that that is something what we
are going to do as well. Yeah. Uh so
based on the four things that I
mentioned so if you would like me to
summarize what we are going to do in
this year next year I think we are
moving from the era of training models
to training agents we are actually
training the agents uh not only with
scaling with pre training but also
skating with RL especially with the
environment we are actually training the
agents so uh I think we can say that we
are now staying in
uh era of
agents. Yeah, that's all. Uh thank you
very much uh for listening to my talk
and if you are interested uh in quen uh
shoot me an email and talk to me in X.
Um yeah, thanks a lot.